salut l'on a tendance à croire que de
notre pensée nous vient des mots est en
fait celle inverse les mots qui fabrique
notre pensée en toute logique si on
arrive à changer le sens des mots alors
ont peu influencé la pensée d'une
personne aujourd'hui je vous parle de l'
influence par les mots
[Musique]
la voix de mon martyrs ressemblait plus
à celle de porcine et ce sont de petits
cadeaux que j'ai eu à la fin du
spectacle à toulouse merci il tendit du
spectacle continue puisque ce mois ci je
serai en occitanie à montauban et puis
ce mois ci je serai aussi en paca à
senna c'est un grand test à mulhouse et
à la vidéo 6/3 paris comme d'habitude
les dates de tournée selon la
description donc j'étais en train de
vous dire au tout début de la vidéo on
pense avec des mots ces mots détermine
notre manière de penser si on n'avait
pas les mots on note penser serait un
petit peu confuse un petit peu nébuleuse
un petit peu sensible c'est le fait
d'avoir mis des mots qui ont formé une
pensée construite mais les mots influe
donc directement sur la pensée c'est
bien bien clair tout ça si on change un
petit peu les mots on peut changer notre
manière de penser
c'est ce qu'ont compris les grandes
instances depuis longtemps mettre en
place des concepts positif pour éviter
aux gens de penser négativement myplace
je vais vous donner un exemple très
concret on parle de youtube heures ou
d'influenceurs de vidéastes et
d'influenceurs un vidéaste ou un youtube
heures c'est un mot qui représente
directement un savoir faire une action
il a fait quelque chose donc il est ce
quelque chose il fait des vidéos
c'est un vidéaste il met du contenu sur
youtube c'est un youtube un influenceur
c'est un autre sens il existe avec une
communauté il va être capable de
l'influencé pour dire ce que je veux moi
donc je vais pouvoir exploiter sa
position et pourtant vous avez vu qu'on
parlait de la même personne donc suivant
le terme qu'on définit on change notre
pensée parce que là si je pense à un tel
comme étant influenceurs je vais pas
avoir les mêmes pensées qui me viennent
que si je pense à intel entend de
vidéastes c'est aussi pour ça que j'aime
pas trop qu'on m'appelle influenceurs
durant la guerre du golfe il avait dit
ça on avait transformé le bombardement
le bombardement cd des bombes qui
explosent et n'importe où qui faisait
des ravages c'était devenu des frappes
chirurgicales avec le mot chirurgicales
ont rattaché des images de précisions on
a tué exactement la personne qu'on
voulait c'était presque des snipers les
bombes
il ya une excellente vidéo de franck
lepage que je vous mettrai aussi dans la
description où il explique la différence
entre le terme exploiter le terme
défavorisés il ya des dizaines d'années
on disait qu'un ouvrier était un
exploité c'est l appellation quoi
exploiter donc issus d'une exploitation
de la part de quelqu'un et on a
transformé ce mot petit à petit en
défavorisent est donc là c'était juste
pas de chance c'est le hasard dans la
vie courante également vous devez faire
attention aux mots que vous recevez aux
mots que vous prononcez pour voir si
vous n'êtes pas manipuler vous parle à
personne qui est en train de vous parler
directement ou si vous n'êtes pas
manipuler vous également par quelque
chose de plus gros que vous qui vous a
mis une nouvelle idée dans la tête dans
le monde de l'entreprise avant il y
avait le licenciement de masse mais
heureusement c'est devenu du plan social
pour sauvegarder les emplois
c'est plus pareil c'est ce qu'on appelle
un euphémisme les eaux femis mais aussi
il ya les oxymores on ne dit plus
récession depuis très longtemps parce
que récession on comprend quand tu vois
non on dit la croissance négative donc
une oxymore parce que ça ne va pas du
tout ensemble mot croissance est
négative et bondissent à aujourd'hui on
dit qu'on est en période de croissance
négative
donc ça monte mais à l'envers confucius
disait et confucius était pas l'année
dernière qui disait ça il disait si
j'étais en charge de gouverner je
commencerai par rétablir le sens des
mots que c'est pas d'aujourd'hui qu'on
s'est aperçu qu'on pouvait se faire
manipuler la pensée par le sens des mots
avant de faire cette vidéo je me suis
amusé à analyser plein de choses comme
des mots tels que suffrage universel si
on prend le sens littéral des mots ce
serait un suffrage universel si on avait
réellement nous mêmes choisi les
personnes pour qui on avait voté en fait
on est un choix définis au départ on n'a
pas choisi ce voilà c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup en politique que j'ai trouvé
des exemples et dans le monde dans
l'entreprise aussi c'est pareil avant on
disait plus les salariés on disait les
salariés surtout dans les start up dans
une grosse boîte on disait les salariés
aujourd'hui on est tous devenus des
collaborateurs et parce que le salarié
en fait il reçoit un salaire pour faire
une tâche le collaborateur il vit pour
le projet il doit donner de son temps de
son énergie il doit tout faire pour que
le projet réussisse le mot projet aussi
beaucoup utilisé maintenant dans les
entreprises parce qu'on est tous des
collaborateurs autour d'un projet quand
tu arrives à lire un mot du langage tu
arrive aussi à bagnères des idées donc
dans un one to one ou dans une
surpopulation on peut faire en sorte de
changer les idées et les pensées avait
remarqué que depuis quelques années on
ne parle plus du tout d'échec scolaire
s'est terminée ce mot n'existe plus on
appelle ça je trouve qu'ils ont été
champions là dessus une réussite différé
mais c'est parce qu'il a récité différé
c'est qu'il a foiré son année bon ben
c'est pas grave trouver une solution
analysons les causes prenons chacun nos
responsabilités sur l'échec scolaire à
ce moment là bas aujourd'hui a plus
besoin de trouver les causes et de
prendre de responsabilités puisque c'est
pas un échec
c'est une réussite différé est juste un
petit peu de retard pour
l'agroalimentaire consciemment ou
inconsciemment je ne sais pas du tout où
j'arrive pas à trouver des sources à
quel moment ça c'est fait mais pareil en
préparant cette vidéo je me suis rendu
compte que on nomme que très peu les
animaux qu'on consomme alors je l'avais
jamais conscientiser jeu les
conscientiser là
en préparant tout ça moi quand je vais à
la ferme je vois des poules dans le
jardin je trouve les p'tites poules
mignonne etc
par contre je mange du poulet tu vas le
même animal à la base mais en disant
poulet on enlève l'image de ces petites
poules de la même manière on élève des
vaches mais on mange du boeuf et si tu
vas au salon de l'agriculture tu verras
des cochons alors que tu mange du porc
on a réussi comme ça a changé dans notre
esprit l'image qu'on avait des animaux
qu'on consomme pour pas se sentir
coupable c'est très malin tout ça et ça
devrait être une des premières fois
qu'en préparant une vidéo moi aussi je
prends conscience d'au-delà de ce que je
voulais dire au départ si vous aussi là
maintenant ça vous fait un petit truc
dans la tête de la [ __ ] c'est ouf mais
tu es un petit laïque pour le signifier
parce que moi ça m'a fait une émotion un
peu un peu étrange de de m'apercevoir
que c'était encore plus fréquents que ce
que je pensais
j'ai vu quelque chose de très
intéressant d'un linguiste suisse qui
s'appelle chaussures et autant vous dire
que saussure c'est une pointure dans son
cours de linguistique générale saussure
nous dit psychologiquement abstraction
faite de son expression par les mots
notre pensée mais qu'une masse amorphe
et indistincte philosophe et linguistes
se sont toujours accordés à reconnaître
que sans le recours des signes nous
serions incapables de distinguer deux
idées d'une façon claire et constante
est rien et distinct avant l'apparition
de la langue vous voyez ce n'est pas une
idée reçue que les linguistes atteste en
fait que les pensées proviennent des
mots il ya un passage dans mes livres
préférés qui est de l'autre côté du
miroir de lewis carroll d'un petit dial
is c'est de la gloire pour toi je ne
comprends pas ce que tu veux dire par
gloire répondit alice d'un petit sourire
d'un air dédaigneux naturellement que tu
ne sais pas tant que je ne te le dis pas
je voulais dire c'est un argument
décisif pour toi mais gloire ne signifie
pas argument décisif objets thalys
lorsque j'utilise un mot déclare adam ti
avec gravité il signifie exactement ce
que j'ai décidé qu'il signifierait ni
plus ni moins mais le problème dit alice
c'est de savoir si tu peux faire en
sorte que les mots signifient des choses
différentes le problème dit des outils
et de savoir qui commande c'est tout
c'est en relisant ce passage que je vous
ai mis ce petit truc sur les réseaux
sociaux ce matin si vous me suivez sur
facebook twitter ou un stagiaire mais
j'ai mis une petite phrase un peu
rigolote et si vous me suivez pas les
liens sont dans la description c'est
encore une fois de garder son esprit
critique vis-à-vis de tous à la
prochaine vidéo je sais pas si je vais
ressortir la dans la semaine ou samedi
et je ne sais pas si ce sera les
résultats de l'expérience mental qu'on
avait fait il ya quelques semaines vous
a été extrêmement nombreux à participer
je mets beaucoup de temps à traiter
toutes les données parce qu'il y en a
une
une foule il ya encore une vidéo cette
semaine mais il y en aura peut-être
encore deux et je peux pas vous dire
quand est ce qu'elle sorte exactement si
vous êtes abonné cliquez sur la petite
cloche qui a à côté du abonnez vous
savez où aller cette cloche comme ça
vous aurez la notification il voulait
raterai pas et si vous avez des exemples
vous aussi de manipulation par les mots
que vous aimeriez m'expliquer mettez les
mois dans les commentaires je veux dire
tout ça avec plaisir je prendrai le
temps de vous répondre demain à tout ça
mais j'aimerais bien qu'on ait encore
d'autres exemples peut-être d'autres
exemples de la vie courante
je vous ai utilisé surtout ceux des
industriels du système scolaire du
système politique mais je suis sûr que
vous avez plein d'exemples comme ça en
oxymore en euphémisme aux autres âmes
donné comme d'habitude n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner avant de partir à très
bientôt ciao